Anxiety can actually be beneficial in some situations. For example, let's say
you're anxious about studying for your final, well that anxiety can jump start
you to actually start studying for the final in an effort to relieve your
anxiety. However, for some people, anxiety can become excessive, which can lead
to a anxiety disorder. Now, there are a number of these types of disorders,
from generalized anxiety disorder to post traumatic stress syndrome, even
social anxiety disorder. In fact, obsessive compulsive disorder used to be
listed in the DSM as an anxiety disorder. However, in the newest version of the
DSM, it now has its own chapter. Research looking at the cause of anxiety
disorders, looks at both genetic and environmental factors. As with many other
topics, psychologists use twin studies to determine what's a genetic cause, and
what's an environmental cause. And using a variety of techniques, researchers
have found the amygdala, and hippocampus, play an important role in most
anxiety disorders.